Avery Kim: Today’s focus: feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: Let’s capture action items clearly on feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: Risk: flaky tests for feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: Risk: scope creep for feature flag rollout plan.
Riley Chen: We need to timebox the spike on feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: I think we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Samira López: Infra-wise, We need to align with capacity.
Noah Williams: Risk: accessibility gaps for feature flag rollout plan.
Priya Singh: From design side, Specifically for feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; parallelize testing.
Noah Williams: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; start with a spike.
Samira López: I propose we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: From design side, We need to align with capacity.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Risk: scope creep for feature flag rollout plan.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Priya Singh: We need to timebox the spike on feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Samira López: Edge cases around auth and retries on feature flag rollout plan.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Noah Williams: Let’s keep this within this sprint on feature flag rollout plan.
Riley Chen: I propose we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: We should add a feature flag on feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Jordan Patel: Observability dashboards for errors on feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: We should add a feature flag on feature flag rollout plan.
Priya Singh: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on feature flag rollout plan.
Noah Williams: My take is we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Observability dashboards for errors on feature flag rollout plan.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on feature flag rollout plan; parallelize testing.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Riley Chen: Edge cases around auth and retries on feature flag rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: I think we split feature flag rollout plan into two subtasks.
Samira López: From design side, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Noah Williams: Action: write migration.
Noah Williams: Risk: data migration for feature flag rollout plan.
Samira López: Okay, who can take ownership?
Samira López: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Noah Williams: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.